[Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you're gonna like this where you going  every dance to go - lets go  [Music]  stuff  [Music]  and most important no matter how much  they beg never never let them eat after  midnight it's right here right it's  looking at me  [Music]  chronologically or six standard a  physically stuff thank you  fire and brimstone coming down from the  skies rivers and seas portal introduces  dark the first widow the dead rise  I thought the camp  [Music]  he slimed me that's great  here cut out the same thing that you  karate - yes karate - no much wax off  you're yesterday's news  got a great kid talent it's not enough  [Music]  there is a time to every purpose under  heaven  [Music]  you came back to me  why would you do this because the needs  of the one outweigh the needs of the  many  [Music]